hello and welcome to this video I am uy
scuti no name okie dokie for put Vinny
Qatar style set up ok so it seems like
he is playing for quickie d5 maybe maybe
he gets a 10 Oh is very relaxed about
his bishops just giving me the light
squared Bishop Bishop floor Elizabeth
maybe bit in precise ok and he likes to
give me a center and so let's seem
Wow even this move is kind of
interesting let's try that I have find
out Bishop f3 actually what is he doing
that after the sugar 3 the great move g6
oh ok that's actually not a big deal
here attacking c7 and queen so very
likely trade trade queens is coming 27
maybe
now Bishop f3 earlier was disastrous for
black already and why I didn't play it
saw it just too late
a couple of interesting ideas you a
decent Queen gvoice is already quite
nice I think 24 is very annoying I'm
taking a screen and if you trades H
takes the night is gone
has to deal with that something like g6
I can I can put my maybe I can play have
six against that so what are you doing
in three this the check or what what is
the point here for sure if three of the
chick doesn't do much
trying to take the Queen and the night
then okay possible it should be fairly
nice
what the easier for him to call you need
now
so this is the easiest thing to do I
think age 49 h5 you cannot cover they
have six pawn okay okay i will give
eight but still not great night comes
over to see six okay
okay i want to screw this up with bad
time management so going to be quick i
now look c5 and then check
ni seven wins apiece just one day I have
something better you know Knight takes
you five is possible I just got the
check okay win the peace calm check
check
anything you can maybe do with some look
at seven and then for the D porn but
shouldn't you shouldn't pan out
time warning so let's see i can check
approach there I can't f 3 has this one
check what's the easiest way to do this
come along with the rope him check black
resigns okay cool and what's tricky I
think I missed that I said in a very
good chance early on just bishop where
three looks crushing he has to go here
and then I have Bishop takes age 50 f5
and both look fantastic and something
like this looks that's just terrible so
engine is up to 1.7 and now that is very
strong I mean this is good as well but
the other thing is just far more far
more terrifying when the kadai engine
likes my play I hear Bishop i3 was
better but okay as long as I keep keep
an edge I rook c1 given by the engine
keep the tension yeah but just this
cannot be all that bad
yeah plus one at least yeah this is a
very tough decision this move him f6 it
probably was also worried that I would
play up six myself but now I'm I have
this long term thing with the poor 96
yeah yeah fighting for that square ok
computer ph 3 yeah this is kind of
logical what I did yeah I think check
amazing the engine oh now it keeps vitac
latch okay I was very surprised it first
it gave this as equal I cannot believe
that this could be equal against those
pawns check check and yeah very good
coordination so check it's no shock big
danger there with the pawns okay a good
win against a high rated opponent thanks
for watching